so you're not from around I've had one
of the most wild entrances into the MCU
it was perfect for me it was an
incredible experience working with
Marvell
first time I read this script I thought
they killed it I thought it was a really
fun entertaining bit of writing just
like we found great set pieces lots of
humor first day on set was exciting kind
of the first day at school isn't it you
a bit nervous it was really exciting a
little bit nervous it felt like a fan
who had a chance to just room set for a
while until I realized that I was
looking there to work the first thing I
did was I first grow fight day when she
laid my ass in escrow for working with
free felt very at home very comfortable
she's inspiring she's a leader and she
was committed and wonderful to work I
could feel her energy I felt what she
wanted from the movie and I felt what
her trajectory would be it felt like two
women who knew what they wanted to
represent her further faster babies you
marry nicholas joseph fury there's three
names everybody calls me fury watching
sam jackson is just a masterclass in
itself did you have a rough day agent
fury a typical nine-to-five he's like
King Marvel he's such a legend and
somebody who I've admired for so long
you want to get personal
that's a photon blast we met with a few
cats and he immediately stole my heart
and we just knew upon meeting him that
he was the one I loved working with him
who's a good kitty huh huh first time we
met Richie we were coming down the hall
where Reggie comes out of nowhere and he
I did that mark I'm very impressed with
the fact that he hit his mark every time
it was all about Reggie we were taking
the mick out of the fact that he's the
star cast member kind of refreshing to
not have to play the badass all-knowing
Nick Fury
it was interesting seeing myself in a
wig I didn't believe it with me Oh
everything just looks so real and
amazing that I really believed that I
was in this alternate universe teams
here are so amazing we were working with
the best visual effects supervisor the
best special effects the best props
everybody was so amazing at their job
that it was completely humbling
everyone's so loving and supportive that
every day has felt fun I think that's
what makes for the magic that you see on
screen it felt great to represent and
women in the military so it felt like a
real honor actually it's such an honor
to be part of this legacy of characters
and story telling us so incredibly
meaningful to people
[Music]